[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es Karim Khan el
fiscal jefe de la Corte Penal
Internacional nos acompaña desde la sede
de la corte en la haya muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros señor can
encantado de estar con ustedes Gracias
Marc
este viernes la cpi emitió dos órdenes
de arresto en el marco de la
investigación que abrieron hace un año
en Ucrania
una de las órdenes es contra el propio
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
la otra es contra la comisionada rusa de
los derechos del niño María liebo
babelova por crímenes de guerra en
particular por la deportación ilegal de
niños de Ucrania a Rusia
Cuál es la dimensión histórica de este
día para la cpi
es un día importante lo fundamental no
es que sea histórico sino la evidencia
que llevó a él
pero también es un día triste porque un
jefe de estado un comandante en jefe de
un país grande poderoso y muy importante
que es miembro permanente del Consejo de
Seguridad ha recibido una orden de
arresto en su contra
Y creo que eso no debería alegrarle a
nadie es un momento sombrío que además
muestra que la ley no es una simple
espectadora ni está ausente
sino que debe limitar ciertos
comportamientos y que ningún individuo
tiene la libertad para cometer crímenes
que hacen parte de la jurisdicción de la
corte en particular genocidio crímenes
de guerra o crímenes contra la humanidad
Así que es un día importante es la
primera vez que un jefe de estado de uno
de los miembros permanentes del Consejo
de Seguridad es acusado
y esto también muestra que la oficina
está actuando con más agilidad en medio
de las balas y bombas en la zona de
guerra que es Ucrania el portavoz del
kremlin dijo que y los cito la orden de
arresto es indignante e inaceptable me
imagino que esperaban una reacción así
poco importa si la esperaba o no esas
declaraciones No me interesan lo que
siempre le aconsejo a cualquier
individuo que esté en desacuerdo con la
ley es que se entregue a la justicia el
que le presente su caso a ella No a mí
Yo solo soy el fiscal
tenemos jueces independientes e
imparciales que han demostrado ser
Audaces y absolutamente capaces de
separar la ficción de los hechos y el
caso Debería ser presentado ante ellos
así que si cualquier persona cualquier
parte o cualquier sospechoso piensa que
un caso es frívolo debe presentarse ante
la Corte presentar su caso a los jueces
y tener la confianza de hacerlo
en concreto que cambia para Vladimir
Putin esta orden de arresto emitida por
la cpi
disculpe no escuché la primera parte de
la pregunta en concreto que cambia para
Vladimir Putin esta orden de arresto
emitida hoy
no estoy seguro de lo que cambia para él
a nivel personal lo que demuestra Es que
la Corte Penal Internacional se ha
movido hemos hecho nuestro trabajo hasta
aquí en relación con este aspecto de
nuestra investigación
los jueces lo han analizado y han
emitido las órdenes ahora lo que sí
significa
Es que la única Corte Penal
Internacional permanente del mundo ha
emitido órdenes contra él y contra la
señora
leoba belova y eso Por supuesto tiene
unas implicaciones en cuanto a la
obligación que tienen los estados de
colaborar con nosotros pero
también en cuanto a la integridad del
tipo de evidencias que hemos escuchado y
que otros han redactado que los jueces
han analizado y según las cuales hay un
caso por el cual responder
los efectos los dirá el tiempo
obviamente quizás resultó más fácil
recopilar esta evidencia por el hecho de
que Rusia de manera muy abierta ha dicho
Sí estamos trayendo niños porque
esencialmente es un gesto humanitario y
estamos promoviendo que las personas los
adopten la señora llevo babelova pidió
públicamente que los rusos adoptaran
niños
Vladimir Putin está facilitando que se
conviertan en rusos entonces El caso es
bastante sencillo para la cpi
Bueno lo que prohíbe la ley
internacional y la deportación o el
traslado ilegal de civiles y los niños
son el grupo más vulnerable
el comité Internacional de la Cruz Roja
los comentarios de la convención de
Ginebra
también hacen énfasis en la importancia
del margen de protección que se le debe
otorgar a los niños ahora siendo una
potencia invasora o parte de un
conflicto es necesario establecer si los
niños están en peligro en una ubicación
particular Y si son trasladados por
supuesto Ucrania es un país grande uno
esperaría que los niños sean llevados a
otra región de Ucrania si por alguna
razón eso no fuera posible las
convenciones de Ginebra y los
comentarios insisten en que se puede
acudir a países terceros neutros que
puedan proveer un lugar seguro pero en
vez de eso parece que se ha establecido
una política que se ha tomado un rumbo
según el cual estos niños han cruzado
límites internacionales y no sólo eso
diseñado ucraniano sino ruso les han
entregado pasaportes y los están dando
en adopción a pesar de que tienen
familiares en Ucrania y de que sus
ambientes familiares están en Ucrania
eso no está permitido según la fiscalía
y ese caso esa tesis ha llevado a que
los jueces de la cámara de asuntos
preliminares de la Corte Penal
Internacional emitieran las órdenes
ustedes también han investigado los
ataques de Rusia contra la
infraestructura civil de Ucrania Esa es
la siguiente área en la que actuarán
los segmento las áreas de hecho lo que
dije mucha en abril del año pasado
cuando fui a bucha y a Boro Bianca
es que desafortunadamente Ucrania se ha
convertido en una escena del crimen hay
muchos alegatos de soldados desarmados a
quienes les han disparado
el mundo hizo públicos alegatos sobre
maripol sobre la sala de maternidad y el
teatro
hay alegatos de tortura contra
prisioneros de guerra de violencia
sexual y de género y por supuesto
también de ataques contra objetivos
civiles
es un ejemplo la infraestructura también
nuestro trabajo es tratar de enfocar
nuestros recursos de la manera más
efectiva e inteligente posible para
llegar a la verdad para el análisis tal
como debemos hacerlo y un aspecto
maravilloso del sistema del Derecho
civil y del artículo 54 del estatuto de
Roma es ver la evidencia incriminadora Y
absorbente por igual no para obtener un
resultado sino para obtener justicia
para llegar a la verdad que después
podemos evaluar y de ser necesario
presentar ante los jueces Así que todas
las áreas de posibles actividades
criminales son áreas de interés para mi
oficina enfocaremos nuestros recursos
basándonos en una variedad de factores
para asegurarnos de que la ley sea lo
más efectiva posible mi propia opinión y
lo he dicho durante años incluso antes
de mi elección
Es que la ley no puede estar ausente de
las áreas de hostilidad de las áreas de
abuso debemos ser más ágiles los hombres
y mujeres de mi oficina han hecho un
trabajo fantástico en una zona de guerra
hemos construido alianzas nuevas e
importantes en euros con el objetivo
investigador adjunto con las autoridades
nacionales y sobre todo con el gobierno
de Ucrania
también he tratado varias veces de
hablar con las autoridades de la
federación rusa porque no tengo agenda
política mi oficina no es política esta
corte no es política esta corte es hija
de nuremberg y nuestra obligación es
tratar de aplicar la ley de me gusta
independiente e Imparcial eso es lo que
hemos hecho y eso es lo que Seguiremos
haciendo
Ucrania ha estado presionando para que
se establezca un tribunal especial para
juzgar El crimen de agresión contra
Rusia
el argumento principal es que Vladimir
Putin no puede ser llevado ante la cpi
Entonces se necesita un tribunal
especial
una cantidad creciente de países ha
apoyado esta idea la comisión europea ha
abierto una especie de oficina en la
haya Donde usted se encuentra sé que
usted no está a favor de eso la orden de
arresto emitida hoy contra Vladimir
Putin es una manera para la cpi de decir
podemos ir tras los más altos
responsables No necesitamos otro
mecanismo para hacerlo
bueno no estamos redactando el estatuto
de Roma en tiempo real
el estatuto de Roma se escribió hace 25
años y se firmó en Roma y a partir de
ese momento el artículo 27 ha dejado muy
claro que el cargo oficial es
irrelevante
que las inmunidades diplomáticas y otros
tipos de inmunidad no impiden que la
única Corte Penal Internacional
permanente del mundo ejerza su
jurisdicción
todos los estudiantes de derecho saben
desde el principio y la decisión tomada
hoy por los jueces simplemente hace
énfasis en algo que todo el mundo sabe
En cuanto a la jurisprudencia de la
corte
y su capacidad de emitir acusaciones y
órdenes incluso contra jefes de estado o
jefes de gobierno pero esa no es la
razón por la que lo hicimos hemos
seguido la evidencia esa es nuestra
responsabilidad básica y fundamental
como funcionarios de la corte
y con la mayor humildad pero también con
la mayor diligencia platinios posibles
se la presentamos a los jueces
independientes de la cpi
que también la examinaron de forma
independiente y eso llevó a la decisión
que presentaron hoy para concluir usted
abrió una investigación hace un año
presentó esas órdenes a los jueces de
instrucción hace tan solo un par de
semanas y ellos actuaron hoy
esta no suele ser la manera de proceder
de la cpi la han acusado de ser lenta y
de demorarse es esto una nueva era para
la cpi
creo que en conjunto la cpi ha estado
viendo Cómo mejorar he dicho varias
veces que la oficina que yo dirijo ha
sido más ágil y más efectiva y ha
encontrado maneras de hacer que la ley
tenga un impacto pero los jueces han
estado reformando y mejorando sus
procesos y en efecto los estados miembro
han animado a la corte a hacerlo
lo que dio paso a la revisión de
expertos independientes que se presentó
en septiembre de 2020 entonces creo que
de manera colectiva se han hecho grandes
avances a lo largo de los últimos años
en cuanto al imperio de la ley pero el
Imperio de la ley y las operaciones de
la Corte Penal Internacional deben
volverse más efectivas de manera general
y eso es un trabajo en curso creo que de
manera colectiva estamos haciendo lo
mejor posible para que la ley sea
relevante para quienes más la necesiten
pienso que todavía nos falta un camino
pero se han hecho progresos y eso
también se debe reconocer
Karen fiscal general de la Corte Penal
Internacional Muchas gracias por estar
en la entrevista de France 24 desde la
sede de la corte en la haya Gracias a
ustedes por sintonizarla
[Música]